et voilà que cette association
d'abord on lui demande de déposer un
dossier et excusez-moi ça ressemble un
tout petit peu à une république des
copains moi j'ai eu l'impression qu'au
fond monsieur cifaoui rencontre la
ministre il se connaît s'il se côtoient
et au fond on se dit tiens bah voilà un
discours intéressant demandons lui de
déposer son propre dossier ça marche
jamais comme ça la règle est plutôt
l'inverse les associations ont une
activité et du coup on reconnaît cette
activité il réponde un appel à projet et
il dépose et on instruit cette demande
de subvention là on leur dit bah déposer
votre dossier et puis il demande 650 000
euros pour quelqu'un qui en avait 50000
en gros tout ça se passe où avec le
cabinet
de Marlène Schiappa qui a d'ailleurs
décidé de faire remonter l'instruction
des dossiers de subvention du cipdr au
niveau du cabinet donc
personnellement je trouve ça n'est pas
bien que ce soit un cabinet qui
instruise des demandes de subvention aux
associations je pense que le comité
interministériel dirigé par un préfet je
préférerais que ça reste dans
l'administration si vous voulez et par
ailleurs on définisse les critères de
sélection et les processus de sélection
là rien de tout ça donc une association
qui vive au TEC qui d'un seul coup se
voit doté qui demande 650 000 € et 1
million cinq sur trois ans on leur redit
dans rabattre un tout petit peu ils ont
donc 355000 euros qui sont attribués il
nous explique ce président qu'il a dû
faire plusieurs demandes en discutant
avec le cipdr pour
réajuster un peu la proposition pour
qu'elle soit bien conforme et qu'elle
rentre dans les règles
et leur production
bon il nous a dit on a choisi de faire
de la qualité
il nous a aussi des dizaines de postes
sur Instagram en un an quelques vidéos
avec quelques centaines de vues
5008 350 5000 euros
j'ai des associations dans ma circo qui
m'ont dit mais nous on postule on
postule on peut faire beaucoup plus de
tweets que ça
[Musique]